كاد ان يسقط لي في اخطر عمليه ضد منذر
الثوره البلشفيه فكان اخطر جواسيس عصره
واكثر مراوغه لدرجه انه سجل براءه اختراع
وهميه باسمه وباع واشترى سلاح طمعا في
المال والسلطه فخدام بريطانيا اكثر من
البريطانيين الاصليين
في ايديهم فمن هو سيدني اسمه الاصليه
عام
كذلك عاش طفوله غامضه حيث انهيه والده
الحقيقيه
درس الكيمياء في فيينا ثم انتقل للبرازيل
حيث تقرب من ضباط الجيش البريطاني
فرشح للمخابرات البريطانيه في لندن حيث
اصبح اسمه اعتبارا من عام
سدني جورج رايلي
تقمص شخصيات مختلفه فتاره هو تاجر اسلحه
وتاره كيميائي يقدم ادويه ببراءه اختراع
وهميه مستفيدا من طلاقه في اللغه الروسيه
والانجليزيه والفرنسيه والالمانيه
والبولنديه
في اواخر القرن التاسع عشر وظفته
المخابرات البريطانيه لمراقبه الاناركيين
الروس في لندن ثم ارسل الى المانيا لسرقه
اسرار الاسلحه حيث اصبح مواطنا بريطانيا
وكان يجني الاموال كوسيق اسلحه دولي
يدعم انه قدم تقارير على مر السنين عن
التطورات النفطيه الروسيه واعمال السكك
الحديديه عبر سبيريا والمساعدات الهولنديه
لجنوب افريقيا حتى انه تنكر في هيئه كاهن
لمنع تاجر النفط الفارسي ويليام دارسين
فرنسا ما خدم امدادات الطاقه البريطانيه
في اعقاب الثوره الروسيه عام
1917 استخدمه البريطانيون مجددا في عمليه
انقلاب ضد النظام البلشفي الجديد وهي
الخطه التي رجح انها تهدف الاغتيال
تروتسكي ولينين لكن عملاء البلاشفه
السريين احبط المخطط فهرب رايلي الى لندن
مع حكم سوفيتي باعدامه
رغم المحاوله الفاشله ارسله بعدها
البريطانيون الى موانئ البحر الاسود تحت
ستار ممثل تجاري لجمع معلومات حول القيام
بانشطه مناهضه للبلشفيه لكنه فشل في مهمته
الاخيره وبحلول منتصف عام
1920 لم يعد رايلي عضوا في الخدمه السريه
من قبل مجموعه الثقه التي تدعي مناهضه
الثوره الى موسكو بحجه استخدامه للمشاركه
في انتفاضه اخرى وهناك قبض عليه عملاء
شيوعيون وسجنوه واستجوبوه واعدموه في
الخامس والعشرين من نوفمبر عام
1925 انتهت حياته رايلي على يد الروس لكن
الشخصيته تمجيدها في المسلسل التلفزيوني
البريطاني عام
و983 ريلي ايس اوفيس بويز كما كتب اخرون
الكثيره عن سيرته